[Applaudissements]
doria 37
j'appelle quand j'ai 25 ans je viens
d'orient avec fred et oman aussi
quelques années grâce à notre première
année yakine ça dure aujourd'hui je suis
informations une pop art il excite
équipe et d'alimentation bio logan pour
le bonjour à toutes et à tous moi c'est
donc thomas je vais inviter à aix en
provence il travailla marseillais dans
une entreprise qui développe le projet
photovoltaïque au signal de mégrit à
scooter
donc voilà j'héritais donc à aix en
provence il faut aussi qu'ils tuent en
réalité à de lyon dont j'ai rencontré
contre 1 à la mi temps
et donc j'ai aussi fait une scène de nu
palme au but hier vous parlez de voyage
elle passe en 2016 depuis donc trois ans
ont expérimenté mais j'insiste ce mot
l'appel général s'ils font plus lors de
différentes façons avec thomas moore ou
est elle standard en passant dwyer
police en vingt ans ça veut dire vous
voyagez en auto-stop
c'est à dire récupérer la nourriture aux
courses noël après d inventer des
commerçants mais aussi de faire la
poubelle c'est aussi faire voler change
au service pour échanger de façon
différente sans mal au secteur de
l'hébergement chez l'habitant l'histoire
est en fait toutes ces façons de voyager
toutes les façons de l'expérimenté
l'homme le voyagement d'argent nous
pousse à l'unité et a lancé au micro
avant mais quand vous voyez sans argent
pour nous c'est bien et c'était pas le
plus important ce qu'on voulait vraiment
c'est avant tout transmettre et
transmettre cette quasi bienveillance
pour entrent quotidiennement dans le
voyage également aussi transmettre la
richesse et la diversité des rencontres
on a pu faire
on est donc et vous les créateurs du
projet sera positive
il est à ce titre allait quand un jeune
vidéaste et conférencier sur le thème
sans argent et on voudrait de poésie les
hostilités de vous inciter par on a
essayé de voiliers j'ai mieux avec moins
donc on a eu comme le consigne
aujourd'hui de parler de l'immense élan
petit c'est pas forcément irrigation
qu'on al'habitude de décrocher qu'on
parlait tous les deux en un plan du
moins pas directement et en fait qu'on y
réfléchisse en cours ou l'immensément
petit c'est le sentiment qu'on
l'accompagné mois quand on sort dans
notre zone de confort et qu'on adopte
une démarche qui est minimaliste
donc c'est vraiment pour nous quelque
chose qu'il y ait pas du tout fatigué et
c'est un petit peu le cas aujourd'hui
ont des dons conférencier pendant deux
conférences sont entre vos vidéos de
voyages nous servent de support pouvoir
se défaire de questions réponses à la
clé et c'est la première fois qu'on fait
rire discours moral unique morale basée
sur un texte avant barker et en cash
back serono un sentiment d'humilité de
petites hausses très bon avancement
bâtisse et 6 pour l'ensemble peu
d'engagement sur vision fin de la
journée pêche mon argent qu'il ya
quelque chose de primordial c'est ce
point les marges - sort après je
trouvais vraiment
à l'argent ça veut dire taper à la porte
les personnes de contrer pas encore ça
se met en position de faiblesse des
fonds va taper à la porte d'une personne
ne sait pas qui est derrière la personne
ne connaît pas mais nous aussi on
n'allait pas et en fait c'est vraiment
se mettre en quelque sort engrangé on se
montre aussi cette sentiments on va
chercher la nourriture points sur 2009
sans argent on va potentiellement faire
les poubelles quelque chose qui paraît
vraiment heureux qu'on n'a pas de toit
brûlant entre éducation et cela nous met
son utilisation un peu timidité la
situation sur laquelle me lapp à
l'affiché de qu'on va faire les
poubelles on va se demander les invendus
aux commerçants parce que nous mangeons
vraiment l'habitude de manier tous nos
échanges et là on va devoir tout
déconstruire
c'est vraiment ce sentiment d'unité
petitesse que l'on retrouve un
brouillage pour d'argent sans argent là
pas l'habitude de faire mal aux échanges
mais doit vraiment y aller parce que
sans les autres on va tous parents
session trouvant un emploi
dormir le soir on va dormir dehors on m
a trié savait très compliqué on a besoin
des autres pour se nourrir tous à ses
besoins fondamentaux se déplacer france
la lettre les autres se nourrir et se
loger sur les autres on peut rien faire
donc en avant la sous direction de
l'unité élèves de plus belle et en fait
si on y réfléchit ces rencontres prouvé
pendant vos voyages qui sont banales
elles sont simples mais en fait elles
sont belles par la simplicité est
vraiment notre approche avec quentin
c'est de faire établir en fait un
contexte surnaturel dans un
environnement qui lui doit rester
et en fait quand on se questionne sur le
voyage sans argent et de manière
générale sur les gros aventure on se
rend compte que l'immense élan petit
c'est pas forcément partir l'ombre du
monde nous contant des mois et des mois
pour besoin d'aventuré ressentir ce
sentiment d'épuisement et l'invention
votre clavier vous le temps d'une soirée
était enquête a même pas 200 m de chez
soi dans son quartier dans cette ville
et qu'en fait c'est vraiment l'intention
collet et sa volonté de se livrer à
l'imprévu qui fait en fait toute la
magie des rencontres et cet aspect
classe collins que quand allemand
recherché à travers ce week-end que les
taux ne sera pas un poids contenu
confiance en support vidéo et digne pour
nous déjà se mettre en danger des
jacinthes shirt petit par rapport à mon
sens personnes qui sont en bas on a
voulu pousser le vous êtes encore plus
beau
en fait on essaie de cette conférence un
élément d'un voyage en fait ce matin est
parti d'un seuil on me décider tout
léger courageuse en arabe c'est tout
mais donc partir d'un seuil comme la
nuance top ici aujourd'hui dj honneur
vous annoncer la parution d'un voyage
c'est un élément loupé à cheval à cette
conférence et je suis en fait la parade
dans lequel je suis parti ce matin
comment est parce qu ils adoptent
aujourd'hui est un et donc qu'ils aient
envie de ça là encore vous êtes le plus
loin et ils ont parlé avec mon temps sur
le dos et apprendre à enlever elle prend
il faudrait qu'on forte encore chez
quelqu'un on va comprendre à son goût
et là on a décidé encore d'enlever une
bouche et donc en fait le sac à dos que
j'ai dernièrement hebdomadaire lui c'est
vraiment le sac à dos avec lequel vous
parle entre nous ne vous inquiétez pas
des beignets port n'est pas
inexpérimenté vandeven qu'on a dû
contrer le projet en 2016
à l'époque on était encore étudiant l
insa de lyon
[Musique]
on était du coup on stage de fin
d'études et on est parti quatre jours l
aventure en auvergne pour un peu se
familiariser avec avec le to stop à des
fédérations nourriture avec
l'hébergement chez l'habitant
ça a été monté une vraie révélation la
confirmation est donc quelques mains
compteur on est parti presque roi sur
les routes européennes of the nation
budapest donc on a fait des milliers
devant des milliers de kilomètres de
rencontrer plus d'une centaine de
personnes et au retour du voyage qu'on a
décidé d'axer un an de transmission du
voyage à travers du coût des conférences
et des vidéos sur internet
on est dans une partie encore de
rejoindre en belgique et bonne foi et
presque maintenant un an en bretagne où
l'idée en fait été de rencontrer un
membre d'autres
et sur internet pour lui proposer de
réaliser ensemble aux défis de
l'histoire il à destination parmi tous
ces voyages n'y a pas de ligue 2 même
chose à raconter
j'aime incroyable choses banales mais il
ya plusieurs années qu'on en rêve pour
raconter maintenant conserve le
sentiment d'humilité vraiment robustesse
on ressent dans l'appellation vin pour
moi le souvenir marquant comme se poser
la question
ce fut entre autres lyon budapest qui a
eu lieu il ya quelques années en automne
on n'a pas trouvé de couleur or on a
passé la france l'italie l'autriche le
remède et en suisse ça faisait deux
jours pour réagir et on avait un gros
sac à dos et des coupes européennes et
notamment on avait une tente de deux
kilos s'était toujours engagé et tous
les soirs en trouver un nouveau raid
aurait aussi laissé quand même deux
couleurs originelles c'est la
bienveillance pour un endroit différent
tu as quand même c'est quand même fort
de café
comme dirait moi même ne pas utiliser
les choses de deux kilos sur le dos et
donc on a dit pas on va aussi alimenter
le bivouac ans qui se comptent n'avait
jamais fait on est en dessous de 10 en
suisse ce qui évoque aeternum on
s'éloigne du village devant un peu la
montagne noire répondant en octobre
novembre
on réalise un saut médaille d'or
motivé et on va ça nuit à un an et sept
mois il fait moins doubler pendant la
nuit c'est pas ça qui te raconter parce
que ça aurait été plutôt fiançailles
matin on apprend degré d'attenté gelés
on commence à rabat où le débit est chu
tu leur as montée qui pour moi une
vacance en fête le soir d'avant attendre
souvent un peu de ressources de pain on
est perdu ou autres matin n'a plus rien
on note notamment à dépenser nos
ressources lunaires je n'ai pas eu du
mal à dormir à -10 degrés est en fait le
fait de nettoyer matin mephisto talent
pour fait quand même utile mais dernière
la dernière énergie ce que l'on
redescend à l'antenne un peu un peu
comme si j'étais bourré et l on arrive
premier village est là en fait le
premier left foot le premier bar électro
totalement sur la table parce que
j'étais au vu des forces en fait et à ce
moment là je voudrais être tellement
commun pour avancer pour retrouver de
l'énergie de la nourriture plus
d'énergie puisque beaucoup plus haut
plus guerrière coule doucement qui la
première a un fils qui a deux ans pour
demander à rendre mon fait limpide et la
necsa vendu trop à gaza et à catane
propose de venir chez elle
au petit déjeuner les geeks ou thomas
vient me chercher et on est allé
chercher à tort n'est pas si matinée
incroyable vous à réchauffer le corps
avec les boissons chaudes clockers
d'être interdit suivant
et c'est vraiment erreurs et en fait
grâce à une lettre à grâce à thomas j'ai
pu avancer les sens sans hésiter par an
une situation de faiblesse et et
sentiments d'impunité que défendre et
bon vent aux autres le temps d'essayer
de leur pouvoir compter sur une anecdote
ce qui rend ces à ce sentiment
d'humilité infiniment petit qu'on peut
ressentir en voyage
c'était donc c'est presqu'un an qu'on
est parti en direction la bretagne ont
ça va être dans une ville juste avant
d'arriver vers heinze et l fougères en
l'air toute la journée à faire du stop
c'est très compliqué pour nous et du
coup on arrive un petit peu tard la
fraude gère la fougère pardon et s'était
du coup le moment où on fait les
commerciaux ont donc plus possibilité de
faire de la récupération donc de
nourriture jetée de cracher les données
ensemble donc on se retrouve très
fatigué il a plu aussi n'ont pas trempé
on était du coup sans avec quelques
rations de nourriture pendant cette
attaque du coi l'hébergement chez
l'habitant et malgré mon goût de faux
espoirs il reste flou et en fait on a du
mal à 22,0 se retrouve du coup sans
hébergement la clé en plus des en fait
une mauvaise rencontre qu'il met un peu
le moral dans les chaussettes et donc il
est 22h du quartier opéra
et toutes les maisons faites sont
éteintes plus personne de de conscience
on se retrouve à faire du porte-à-porte
fait cette maison à lui mais c'est en
fait la maison d'alfred est le film à
peine
donc on est fatigué je vous présentons
nos très présentable pas trop ça moi
aussi bon pour expliquer le contexte de
la démarche et la confiance tu pouvais
s'installe pas été alfred un peu apeurée
est tout de même bien veillant dans
propose du coup de nous héberger à celle
du coupé ce qu'il n'avait pas confiance
mais autant son garage donc et en
échange de nous lever d'identité qui
leur fait sauver sa peau en caution pour
garantir entre guillemets un échange
pérenne donc on y danse retrouva les
craintes à manger nos quelques restes de
nourriture qu'on avait sur nous d'en
face de la porte du garage tant que dans
la rue vous et ce moment là va marquer
parce que je me suis vraiment fait se
mit à la place de personnes qui vivent
cette situation
une grande majorité de la vie parce
qu'il souhaitait être par exemple dans
en france et est du coup je me suis
vraiment senti dans cet état d'esprit de
petites et cette dépendance spécialisés
de l'autre c'est assez fort alors on
l'avait choisi
nous pointons et des témoignages avec
notamment la pose pour avoir la cote est
de poser est ce qu'on amène vous faire
vivre maintenant c'est une aventure
impressionnèrent en fait ce qu'on vous
propose demain on va se réveiller
on sait encore où et on va partir en
stop et et si vous avez envie je vous
propose en fait nous rejoindre et que
vous aussi vous découvrir l'auto stop
vous sortir de votre zone de confort que
vous exprimez petit quelque chose avec
nous et si ça vous choque que nous
rejoindre devant la tente ou même sort
aussi qu'on retourne un hébergeur
dérangement petit pour thomas et moi
c'est reconsidérer l'absence de choses
quotidiennes qui pourrait paraître
insignifiante serait revenue au taf avec
une épaule est clairement un collectif
qui s'appelle le pronostic du jour
vous faites peut-être aussi c'est un pas
positif ce qui ce qui m'apparaît vont
essayer de trouver un monde alors j'en
ai qu il apparaît que ce tristement aux
festivités pas confier un projet que
l'on commençait à six mois son fils
marathon paris c'est tout simplement que
d'être assassiné quelque chose qu'ils
ont réussi qui l'on parle de kaka est
référent la rue et ça s'est bien passé
ça peut être n'importe mode de
transmission mais en fait nous rend
heureux au quotidien moi j'ai aussi un
autre exemple pour reconsidérer
élections du quotidien avec ma copine on
a créé une boîte dans laquelle on met
des petits hauts où on écrit des défis à
réaliser ensemble et en fait
régulièrement lorsqu'on a du temps avant
qu'elle ait une soirée monsieur charmant
de la boîte et du coup on réalise ce
défi ensemble de manière du corps encore
mieux le connaître et aussi parfois qui
l'ont aidé à tenir un petit peu en
matière routière avec des couleurs plus
de moments insolites et du coup je
voudrais aussi avant de conclure notre
speech offert une invitation et vous
proposez chacune et chacun d'entre vous
collectivement individuellement de date
en fait de faire appel à la créativité
pour aussi vous trouvez des moments des
expériences des situations insolites à
mettre en place dans notre vie pour
faire de récit tient entre guillemets
une aventure de tous les jours le but
derrière ça c'est vraiment d'apprendre à
connaître en profondeur de sortir de ma
zone de confort de découvrir aussi la
personne avec qui vous vivez votre
expérience et donc le site de faire
peut-être des deux des verts parents
certains clichés aux âmes un projet
qu'on pourrait avoir sur une situation
un pays nous donne simplement des gens
on connaîtrait pas forcément qu'on
finirait avec des scènes phrase en tête
qu'il est en question
quelques dents à tanis à son produit et
cette question
moi je m'impose 200 enfants pour sortir
ma zone de confort pour me remettre en
question
aussi peut-être pourrez-vous la pause et
aussi de temps en temps cette question
assurances et c'est quand la dernière
fois que j'étais quelque chose pour la
première fois merci merci
[Applaudissements]